[Música]
bom eu queria que essa fosse a música da
rainha avião c que mais me representasse
mas por muito tempo foi essa aqui flor
they won't e favor a boy
se eu fosse um menino essa foi a música
vocês devem conhecer da abiã sei que me
apresentou por muito tempo porque por
muito tempo muito tempo mesmo eu que
esse é um menino que era tão difícil ter
que lutar pra fazer as coisas que eu
queria toda hora e parecia ser tão mais
fácil se o menino porque não teria que
me preocupar com o problema das vagas do
gênero
eu não teria que menstruar eu não
precisaria usar sutiã eu não me sentir
insegura e com medo o tempo todo eu
poderia sair na rua tranquila e minha
puberdade não atrapalharia a minha
liberdade
no entanto era algo muito natural eu
lutar por esses meus direitos como se
alguém dissesse a claro você não pode
fazer isso porque essa mocinha até hoje
ou mulherzinha menininha brady magrinha
baixinha eu ia lá e fazia e aí meu
apelido virou cria de maria bonita sem
saber nem a mulher valentona que foi a
primeira figura feminina a ingressar no
principal bando de cangaceiros do
nordeste pois é além da beleza que eu
tinha ainda tem um pouco hoje que
ninguém nunca tivesse feito algo antes
eu ia ser a primeira fazer e assim
outras pessoas elas sentiriam
representadas encorajados principalmente
outras meninas
eu não tinha consciência da época mas eu
acredito que eu era uma criança que
queria mudar o mundo porque eu tinha
aquela sensação de querer dá voz a quem
não tinha e poder ser livre para fazer o
que eu quisesse fazer
e foi com esse protagonismo que eu fui
parar no mundo da engenharia elétrica e
se aqui uma foto a postagem do dia da
minha matrícula e eu fui com os meus
pais e quando já estava fazendo a
matrícula uma das pessoas do
departamento falou você tem certeza
quero fazer engenharia elétrica que
investiga assim eu não dou um semestre
no curso
bom já se passaram cinco anos e estou me
formando
esse ano não foi fácil não foi fácil
mesmo eu entrei muito novinha na
universidade eu entrei com aquela
energia e da adolescência estava
passando para a vida adulta e aí com o
tempo as coisas começaram a perder
sentido e depois de dois anos de curso
eu tive que parar se não parei porque eu
sou teimosa o meu corpo para o por mim e
eu tive meu primeiro episódio de
depressão e foi nesse momento que eu
precisei encontrar o caminho de volta
para casa
eu costumo dizer que eu desequilibrei
para poder olhar pra dentro e por isso
que foi um ponto de virada
eu costumo dizer que foi tipo mary com
da minha vida eu fiz uma faxina
botei tudo em cima da mesa viu que me
fazia mal e fiquei só com kimi trazer
alegria e nesse momento da minha vida eu
comecei a entender porque eu tinha
nascido menina e nessa jornada
nessa jornada de autoconhecimento e de
pertencimento a minha essência feminina
eu encontrei o meu propósito ea minha
sogra é astróloga
aí ela falou pra mim olha para você
nasceu com alguém ares para chegar em
libra eu não entendi nada
só entendi equilibra é o equilíbrio e
que eu preciso trazer equilíbrio para o
mundo de alguma forma então meu
propósito se tornou traz equilíbrio para
o mundo
mas o que é que o equilíbrio pra você
porque pra mim não é só um montão de
livro na cabeça
equilíbrio é algo holístico e eu achei
as minhas anotações da primeira vez que
você é meu propósito em 2016 e é baseada
em um tripé o equilíbrio pessoal nos
leva o equilíbrio social que nos leva a
equilíbrio ambiental e assim eu quero
muito mudar o mundo ele começa o
primeiro com meu e eu estava nessa
jornada de autoconhecimento e tálio
sobre equilíbrio eu não preciso e para a
ásia
né ásia é obeso das grandes religiões e
nós ocidentais a gente que acha que quem
asiático é muitos em monjolos paraná 16
meditação e talvez não vou embora prazo
e eu fui de mala e cuia para as
filipinas foi fazer trabalho voluntário
enquanto estudava espiritualidade e
formação humana global e eu morava na
casa com 15 mulheres de 12
nacionalidades diferentes e eu fui
criada só tem um irmão homem então pra
mim era muito estranho está como um
montão de menina pedindo as coisas e
tudo mais
e pra minha surpresa é eu descobri hoje
reconheço que a minha cura foi pelo
feminino porque eu reconheci minha
sombras através das meninas para chegar
luiz e só olhando de verdade pra outra
mulher só olhando para ela em
profundidade é que nós conseguimos sair
de si mesmo e nesse olhar espectral um
salto acontece porque a gente se conhece
sagrada e se iluminou o caminho eu me
senti segura pra confiar no universo
permitia e entende que a verdadeira
liberdade é na verdade não se inquieta
com perfeição
nessa hora eu abracei esse meu lado
feminino entende que é uma metade de mim
muito importante e aceitar você mulher
me fez entender que minha causa era
mulheres porque me movimentar com as
meninas e transformar diversas
realidades desde a equipa estava
aceitando usar o cabelo cacheado até
aflora esse que quer acabar com o
tráfico de mulheres na minha mão e eu
recebi a ligação do brasil era uma cela
fugir
ela estava me convidando para ser com a
fundadora de um acelerador é de mulheres
e aceleradora que o poeta meu deus como
assim
e eu fiz mas ela não da nossa tenho 21
anos eu estou na faculdade todas as
filipinas não dá pra abrir uma empresa
eu fiquei pensando como eu vou agregar
que eu vou obrigar uma empresa porque
quando a gente tá na universidade neste
momento parece que a gente não sabe
fazer nada
ela fez claro o trabalho que vem fazendo
na universidade e nas filipinas é a mais
profunda simpatia com o empreendedorismo
nino e assim mas ela me conheceu quando
em outras meninas mas fundamos o 'menino
engenheiro em mulheres na engenharia no
nosso curso de engenharia elétrica e o
que eu mais queria era trazer equilíbrio
por meu curso de engenharia porque
várias vezes várias vezes mesmo nós
somos bombardeados por professores
colegas de curso até por pais que
duvidam da nossa capacidade e
engenheiras e esse preconceito ele tem
que acabar e eu precisava da voz ali
porque eram das únicas mulheres
esses preconceitos eles são escondidos a
gente às vezes nem tem consciência que
eles existem
segundo os pesquisadores do centro de
gênero nas organizações esses
preconceitos de gênero eles parecem
naturais e neutras em suas faces mas
eles revelam valores masculinas e
pessoas que dominaram o mundo ao longo
dos anos e desde então eu vinha
trabalhando por essa adversidade que nos
une e que traz equilíbrio tanto no
brasil como nas filipinas assim
isso fazia com que a primeira
aceleradora de mulheres do brasil não
existe sem mim e eu topei e fiquei cinco
meses trabalhando como o noma digital no
fuso de 11 horas de diferença e na ilha
de voltar pro brasil inclusive faz um
ano hoje que eu pisei eu estava muito
animada porque é que passado um ano na
ásia me achava a deusa do equilíbrio
nossa linda também editar tudo e só que
assim eu tinha desde o começo que eu
nasci um problema de fazer muitas coisas
ao mesmo tempo então quando eu pisei no
brasil já tem inúmeras responsabilidades
eu tinha que terminar a universidade
internacional a empresa tinha que
continuar com o trabalho voluntário eu
precisava ser rica linda fitness
maravilhosa e eu entrei na nokia como é
que eu tinha 22 anos e não tinha meu
primeiro milhão
comecei a trabalhar muito e
minha agenda não tinha mais espaço pra
minha família não tinha mais fácil
namorada só queria saber meu deus você
fica 22 anos 1 milhão
e aí eu comecei a ficar doente
comecei a ficar doente de novo não
estava dando conta dessas coisas e aí eu
me perdi me pedir mais uma vez
e dessa vez foi muito mais difícil
porque já sabe o que não devia fazer e
eu fui lá e fiz de novo me desequilibrei
de novo foi muito doloroso
eu estava cansada toda hora não
conseguia fazer nada tudo que havia
ganhado um co era pretérito estava tudo
cinza
só que dessa vez eu já sabia o caminho
de volta para casa
eu tinha me desequilibrado porque eu
tinha me distanciado do equilíbrio e
assim gente todos nós possuímos o
energia dominante pessoas como eu que
tem energia masculina muito alta e que
yang muito alto a gente costuma se
perder essa mesma maneira a gente faz
uma porrada de coisas ao mesmo tempo e
esquece da parte que a gente pára e
respira ea soma do yang formam todo e o
efeito disso é a medida que um aspecto
aumenta o outro diminui para manter o
equilíbrio geral do todo então no meu
caso eu precisava focar no feminino
porque essa parte de mim
ela estava se perdendo e eu entendo hoje
que o meu o sagrado feminino e masculino
eles precisam andar juntos abraçados
interligados carinhosamente aquecidos um
pelo outro
eu entendo que o equilíbrio é linda
juntinho com protagonismo porque quando
a gente não tá bem nada fui
absolutamente nada não adiantou querer
fazer todas as coisas ao mesmo tempo
porque desequilibrei e quando a gente
não tá bem nossos projetos não crescem
então pra gente fazer nossos projetos
crescer a gente precisa manter esse
equilíbrio e aí voltamos porque pé
o equilíbrio pessoal nos leva ao
equilíbrio social que nos leva o
equilíbrio ambiental e gente em si
porque eu sou geminiana a pessoas que
acreditem ou não
minha vida uma montanha-russa então põe
açúcar tempero e tudo o que deixa uma
pessoa louca juntas
eu tenho sim um transtorno psiquiátrico
e é muito difícil falar sobre isso
porque a minha maior vulnerabilidade é
difícil conviver com isso todas as horas
do meu dia na minha família quase todo
mundo tem algum tipo de transtorno
diferente e é difícil a gente aceitar
doenças que a sanção não são físicas
elas são sentidas
a gente às vezes não acha que entende e
é desconfortável é confortável feito um
furacão
e falando em furacões eu não sei se
vocês sabiam mas os furacões e
tempestades mais fortes do planeta tem
nome de mulheres e têm várias formas de
se acontecer uma delas me chamou a
atenção do que em 2014 o estudo da
universidade de illinois divulgou que
estes furacões eles matam mais pessoas
porque eles costumam ser elevados - a
sério e aí consequentemente a menos
preparação para enfrentá los
então partimos daí nós percebemos que o
equilíbrio no mundo está bem balanceado
entre o feminino eo masculino e isso me
leva a fazer o que eu faço hoje
e é com essas pessoas que estão
namorando mulheres que transforma a
sociedade e trazendo equilíbrio para o
mundo através da igualdade de gênero
porque o equilíbrio social ele começa o
equilíbrio de gênero em 2º fórum
econômico mundial o brasil ocupa posição
95 no ranking de igualdade de gênero e
nós precisamos de um país seguro e o
país que as mulheres participem a
passagem da economia
nós precisamos de um país seguro e
saudável para as mulheres
nós precisamos de equilíbrio de gênero
nós precisamos de equilíbrio na nossa
sociedade e esse equilíbrio ele
transforma mãe em vários sentidos
segundo pesquisa feita pela rede mulher
empreendedora as mulheres quando elas
elas realmente prosperam
elas investem não só nelas elas em teste
em na casa dos filhos na família na
comunidade onde vivem por isso que elas
são um importante instrumento de
transformação e assim que as mulheres
estão no centro do nosso diálogo porque
nós queremos mudança para fotos e unir
as brasileiras
outra coisa que a gente quer muito é
liberdade do feminino e olha quando falo
de feminino eu não tô falando só do
gênero feminino aqui nós falamos do
feminino de mulheres porque nós
acreditamos que todos nós temos valores
femininas e masculinas só que na nossa
sociedade sobre as femininas eles são
recriminados nossa recriminei eles
porque eu queria gente queria que o
menino não aceitava esse no feminino e
nós queremos um sociedade os valores
femininos eles são vividos e celebradas
valores como acolher e integrar
humanizar o fórum econômico mundial
também divulgou sua pesquisa sobre as
habilidades do futuro e pasmem metade
das habilidades do futuro são
características inerentes ao nosso
feminino
bom o mundo tá evoluindo nossos valores
estão mudando ea gente encaminhando pro
equilíbrio até dos valores que nós
vivemos
então pensando eu tô aqui agora em
maceió do nordeste ainda é muito difícil
ser mulher e entrou não estou agora eu
quero chegar a um longo caminho a
percorrer e eu acredito que a trajetória
não é linear e um caminho muito maluco
para percorrer e acelera mulheres foi a
forma que encontrei de tangibilizar esse
futuro que eu quero um futuro de gênero
não defina como alto você deve sonhar
o colón ge você vai chegar um futuro a
gente passar na rua z poço livre para
fazer realmente aquilo que eu nasci pra
fazer no futuro diversa inclusive
abundante e é por isso que eu vou
continuar fazendo todas essas coisas
porque a gente precisa trazer equilíbrio
para a nossa sociedade
esse não sou eu quem se na gente que vai
pensar com outras equipes para o mundo
quem é que vai trazer então somos
protagonistas de nossa própria história
e bida drop sejam aquela gota que faz
revelações diárias e modem realidades
mas nunca se esqueçam de entrar em
equilíbrio com seu próprio jean ano
porque voltamos ao nosso tripé
o equilíbrio pessoal nos leva o
equilíbrio social que nos leva o
equilíbrio ambiental e vocês podem sim
trazer equilíbrio no mundo começando com
o seu
[Aplausos]